يأتي وقت في أي عرض عن
توسكانا
حيث يتوجه المضيف إلى التلال
الرائعة ويخبرك كيف أن شمس البحر الأبيض المتوسط
اركت مزارع الكروم في توسكانا لم
ة ثلاثة آلاف عام وق
يكون لديهم حتى رشفة مدروسة من نب
ذ توسكان مشهور عالميًا مثل شيانتي كل
سيكو  [موسيقى]
لكنني لن أفعل ذلك ، فأنا ذاهب
في زحف بار قديم الطراز
وعندما أقول الطراز القديم ، أعني
أن عصر النهضة
رائع لرؤيتك أيضًا ، لقد أعاد هذا الشريط الصغير
تقديم 500 عام
في عام 1559 ، أصدر صديقنا القديم ، الدوق الأكبر
كوزيمو بريمو دومينيسي ،
مرسومًا يقضي ببيع الفلورنسيين الأثرياء
النبيذ الذي ينتجون في أراضيهم
مباشرةً من النوافذ الصغيرة المقطوعة في
جدران قصور مدينتهم
بدلاً من الحانات وأصحاب
الفنادق
في أوائل 59 طائرة  مع
محاولة جدران الدين أن تصبح
صعبة في أوروبا ، لذلك كان على هذه العائلة
إعادة ضبط العمل والقيام بشيء
مختلف وبدأوا في تقليل
النبيذ ، وأصبح هذا أمرًا رائعًا  حسنًا في تلك
اللحظة للعديد من العائلات
لأنها كانت من المنتج
والمستهلك
حقًا ، لذا لا يوجد وسيط لا يصنع رجلاً ، لذا ستمشي بنعم
ولن تشتري الزجاج
ولكنك ستشتري مجموعة تشتريها بالإضافة إلى
أنت.  اشترِ شققًا ، نعم ، كان لديهم باب الحراسة الصغير ،
نعم ،
كان هناك جرس في وقت ما كانوا
يضعونه أيضًا مثل القارورة في الأعلى مثل
إعلان ليقول مرحبًا يا رفاق مع بعض
النبيذ
ولكن دعنا نطلب بعض النبيذ ، حسنًا ، دعنا نرى أن
هناك بعض النبيذ كيف تفعل  افعل ذلك ،
هل
تسحبه ، هل أسحب هذا ، إنه جرس ، نعم ،
إنه خفاش ،
هل يسميها شخص ما بطيئًا تقريبًا ، نعم
أوه ،
هذا رائع.
هذا جيد ، هذا جيد ، لقد
اعتقدت دائمًا أن
تذوق النبيذ أفضل عندما يأتي من خلال
النافذة ، نعم ،
لقد حصلت على نبيذ آخر ، نعم ، نعم ، نعم
، يبدو أنه فارغ ، نعم ،
مرحبًا ، كيف يمكنك الحصول على كمية كبيرة أخرى ،
قد يكون هذا زحفًا قصيرًا إلى النبيذ بشكل مخيب للآمال
خليج باربار هو cu  في الآونة الأخيرة
، نافذة النبيذ الوحيدة التي تعمل في
فلورنسا
حتى لو كان لا يزال هناك 130 أو ما
يقرب من ذلك من النوافذ البائدة حول المدينة ،
لا توجد نوافذ النبيذ الصغيرة هذه في
أي مكان خارج توسكانا.
بالصدفة صادفنا
علامة أخرى ولكن العلامة ستكون من الوقت
الذي لا
بأس به ، نعم ،
مرحبًا ، مرحبًا ، مرحبًا ، كيف
حالك؟